Before we move into writing the code for
pitch perfect, I want to cover a softer
pattern that'll be really useful
in your time as an iOS developer.
Let me introduce the MVC pattern to you.
We're going to build the pitch perfect
up using this pattern, so knowing it
will be really handy to figure out
where we are, and where we need to be.
The model view controller pattern
hails back from the Mac development
days of the 80s.
And it's still as useful
today as it was then.
You'll see it called model view
controller or MVC for short.
We can think of our pitch perfect
cap as having three parts.
The view, which the user sees
with the buttons, the model,
which is what was stored to recorded
audio file, and the controller,
which we used to store and retrieve data
from the model and show it in the view.
Think of the data your app contains.
For pitch perfect this
is just an audio file.
But as you progress as an IOS developer,
you will build ever
more complicated apps.
Which you need to store a lot more data.
All of the costs involved
with storing and
maintaining this data can be
referred to as the model.
On the other side of
the diagram we have the view.
The view is what the user sees on screen
and how they interact with the app.
The view does not know anything
about the data itself or
the model as we call it here.
It only knows how to display
the subset of data that it's given.
It is just your user interface.
In between them, and in charge of
providing the view with data and
the model with any
actions from the view.
Is the Controller.
When the user action happens on
the view, the Controller is notified.
If needed, it updates the Model.
When the Model is changed
by some external event,
it notifies the Controller,
which can update the View if needed.
Maybe you're thinking.
Why not just embed all
of the model data code.
Inside the view.
What's often the case that you need
to have multiple different views.
To show some parts of the same data.
What would you do then?
Copy and pasting the code would
quickly turn this project
into what one of my colleagues
refers to as copy pasta.
Great to eat but
horrible to have in your code.
Having a division in
responsibility between the model.
The view and the controller in between
makes your code easy to maintain,
easy to understand, and reusable.
As we start building pitch perfect
together, you're going to see the model,
the view, and the controller parts,
and how they communicate.
Students have found it really
handy to have this pattern and
thought in the back of their minds.
As they are developing for iOS.
It helps to keep your app structured and
easier to develop.